today it's July 5th 2018 so it's time
for another monthly update video in
which I'll talk about what went on in
June and what we've got coming up in
July I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things so the
three big things this month number one
is that by the end of the month we
should have some new courses coming out
in the reason IO teachable Academy so
stay tuned for that big thing number two
in the Sadler's lectures podcast we've
finished up with doing Plato material
and we're now moving to doing some
material on Kierkegaard's work fear and
trembling big thing number three
towards the end of the month here in
Milwaukee we're going to be having our
local MKE Sophia that's the Society of
philosophers in America membership
meeting gearing up for the fall and
hopefully having a good time talking
with some of the membership about what
it is that they would like to do with
the organization so let's talk about the
month of June I didn't get that much
accomplished in part because we had some
family matters going on my my kids came
and visited for a week and I really
enjoy spending time with them but that
means that I spend time with them and
don't do quite so much when it comes to
say video work or podcast work although
my son is now helping out by doing some
editing of podcasts we also had some
some injuries in the household my wife
first had partially injured and then
finally entirely tore her meniscus in in
her knee so that really put her out and
and since we have two old dogs one of
which was seeming to be close to two
passing away but thankfully is going to
be with us for a while longer they
require a lot of attention so
is managing a lot here in the household
in terms of tending to them tending to
her trying to stay on top of things and
trying to get some work done as well so
events wise at the very beginning of the
month
I accepted an invitation from the Turtle
Island Research collective and did an
online session with them which I'll put
a link to below called rather
ambitiously introduction to reading
Hegel and so we did a online hangout
with with them I had to cancel the
worlds of speculative fiction lecture
again because of the the injury and all
the other things that kind of piled up
so we cancelled that and put it off
until August I did manage to hold you
know a few online events the the AMA we
did philosophy pop-ups of course
oriented towards the issue of the body
understood in a philosophical
perspective and I held my two half-hour
Hagel Q&A and discussion sessions I also
attended the Marquette Aristotle and the
Aristotelian tradition conference and
got to hang out with you know some old
friends and colleagues and also you know
the trumble's who came down from Toronto
some some people that I've been involved
with for quite a while mostly in an
online manner but we met at we met up at
stoical on last year which is very nice
and they're a great couple so we got to
chat a bit and and go to the picnic and
then of course we had our MKE stoic
fellowship meeting at the end of the
month we started doing Epictetus
discourse isn't we had a few new people
show up that's always kind of nice to
see I did remain quite busy with
tutorial sessions I actually picked up
some new clients doing consulting work
and doing philosophical counseling I've
also been quite busy developing syllabi
for the classes that I'll be teaching in
the fall for Marquette
and the Milwaukee Institute of Art and
Design I tried to get some writing done
and I did get some work done in Iraq sis
D&O @tk but I didn't get any of the
guest blogging that I wanted to do
accomplished or much in the heavy metal
philosopher or half hour Hagel blog but
I'm hoping to get to that this coming
month video wise I finished up the core
concept videos on Heidegger and started
releasing some of the videos that I had
previously only released to my patreon
supporters on Plato's Republic book 10 I
did five of the half hour Hagel videos I
usually actually get six done a month
but I only managed to get five done and
I released a few Q&A videos and of
course there were videos of the online
events I did however manage to get and
my son helped me out with some of the
editing on a few of these some podcast
episodes in the Sadler's samplers
lectures out on Plato on the apology the
credo and the Euthyphro so all told you
know a pretty busy month I didn't get as
much accomplished as I would like but
it's quite understandable given the
circumstances alright let's talk about
the month of July now so we have a few
face-to-face events and some online
events coming up on July 10th at 5:00
p.m. this is an online event we'll be
having our public half-hour Haegele Q&A
session under written of course by my
half hour Haegele patreon supporters on
the 12th here locally at the Brookfield
Public Library we're gonna have I think
this is probably going to be a kind of a
big draw we're going to be talking about
Robert Howard and the Conan stories that
that he wrote and some of the history of
other people editing those that's part
of the worlds of speculative fiction
series 7:00 p.m. at the Brookfield
Public Library so if you're here in the
area and want to
about classic swords and sorcery and
some of the philosophical themes show up
to that on the 14th at 12 p.m. noon
central time of course I'll be having my
monthly AMA that is ask me anything
session so you can pop in and ask
whatever questions you like and if you
get them in early enough I will
certainly make an effort to answer them
if you wait until the very end we
usually have so many questions that I
can't get to all of them
then on the 26th at 6:00 p.m. here in
Milwaukee at the Shorewood Public
Library we'll be having our MKE stoic
fellowship monthly meeting again going
through Epictetus the second part of
book 1 of the discourses and then on the
28th at the Milwaukee Public Library
central branch 11:30 a.m. we will be
having our
MKE Sophia that society of philosophers
in America chapter membership meeting so
this is for members of course anybody
can become a member if you if you want
to and Sophia is a organization spread
throughout the United States that's
devoted to doing public philosophy that
is bringing philosophy to bear on public
problems and in public ways in in
fostering civil discourse and that's
what we're going to be discussing so a
lot of events happening I will also be
doing my philosophy pop ups I announce
those on patreon at the beginning of the
month and I'll be handling that later
today everybody else finds out the day
of one is in YouTube live one is in
Facebook live and this month I'm going
to talk about the family as a you know
philosophical construct as well as you
know all the other things that it is and
I think that could be quite interesting
for people very busy month ahead in
terms of tutorial sessions more
consulting work with two different
projects philosophical counseling I'm
also still continuing developing the
syllabus
I've got that more or less worked out
from my philosophy of human nature
course my philosophical foundations
course now it's time for me to start
hammering away at the business ethics
course that I'm gonna be teaching for
Marquette in the fall and on revising my
my syllabus and course structure for the
world views and values class that I
teach from Marist also in the fall
online and I'm trying to get more
writing done this month we'll see how
that goes both popular writing and
academic writing and some work on the
the book project doing a lot of
editorial work of course your stoicism
today and I'm also lining up speaking
gigs both for the fall and for first
quarter and second quarter of 2019 so if
you're interested in bringing me in as a
speaker I'm already pretty booked up for
the fall but 2019 is at this point
pretty wide open just write me at Gregg
at reason IO and we'll talk about the
feasibility of whatever it is that you
have in mind you know workshops coming
in to give a lecture facilitating a
discussion I'm game for all of those
things even Ted style talks videos what
am I going to be doing this month well
of course the event videos but I'm also
gonna get my six half-hour Haegele
videos done this month I've got some
more Q&A videos to bring out that is
those answers to common questions I'm
hoping to get you know back into the
doing the book review videos as well and
I'll probably shoot a few personal
videos then there will be core concepts
on Plato I you know I've got one more to
release on republic book ten and I got
to thinking oh there's a lot of other
things in the Republic I haven't gotten
to yet but I should probably do and I'm
shooting videos on Blaise Pascal's
Ponce's as well podcast stuff what can
you look forward to this month some
podcast episodes on Kierkegaard's fear
and trembling and if I get through all
of that I'm going to then turn to Cicero
stoic
paradoxes and start releasing some
podcast episodes on that so a lot going
on this month of July a lot going on in
June my children are going to be here
starting this Saturday for the entire
month of July so I'm really happy about
that that's going to be on the one hand
it's gonna take time away from some of
the work that I do but on the other hand
they're also a great help to me now that
they're older they can help out with
some of the duties and chores and even
some of the editing work and I really
get enjoy getting to spend time with
them and share it with them here in our
great city of Milwaukee so hope that you
have a wonderful month of July and you
know again if you're interested in
talking to me about speaking and any
other services that I've mentioned
tutoring philosophical counseling
consulting academic coaching just write
me at Greg at reason IO calm and we'll
talk about it otherwise hopefully I'll
see you at some of these online events
and perhaps even at some of the
face-to-face events
you